hello everyone and
welcome to rational science the only
site on the internet
that does physics real physics
genuine physics everybody else does
particles and concepts that's what they
move around
and here we talk about something else
we're saying all
atoms all matter in the universe is
interconnected
physically interconnected okay
and so we arrive at a different universe
than all these other people okay
uh last couple times
maybe over a week been talking about the
origin of the universe according to
mathematical physics and also
christianity okay so we have these two
versions
and uh i also uh looked at last time
uh how some of the matter how much
how some of the things uh
were created along the way until today
okay
and again i compared to christianity
against in this case quantum mechanics
because that's the
it's quantum mechanics that tackled this
problem of what happened at different
stages
and today i'm going to add another
ingredient to this story
okay especially to the story of creation
okay from a mathematical physics point
of view
okay which is not physics at all as we
will see
okay okay so um uh the ingredient i'm
gonna
add is called the instantan
okay the instant time you say what the
hell is an instant time
and you might even accuse me and say
well bill you're just gonna give us your
version
no no today you're going to hear from
the horse's mouth from the people who
proposed
and still propose to this day
the instant time and you know forget
about the higgs
everybody thinks that the higgs is the
god particle no no the
instantan is the god particle it's the
one
that triggered creation
according to mathematical physics and
you know i've had this
article from the astronomy magazine
and this dates from 1999
it says how it all began by stephen
hawking
and neil turuk so they're going to tell
us how the universe began they're going
to use the instanton
as the little uh seed
that gave origin to everything okay
so uh what i did was uh put the article
uh in uh in pictures so that you can
see more or less what they were talking
about we're just going to breeze through
that
and you're going to see how the instant
time uh
gave origin to the universe or how the
the uh mathematical physicists even to
this day
are working on the same stuff okay
they're still working
on the instant time so the instantan is
alive and well okay it's the god of
mathematics
okay so here let's go with the first one
uh it says uh how it all began
okay and the the title of the article
was give peace the chance and give peace
a chance
and uh here we have the two of the
ideas that were included in that article
one comes from neil turuk which was like
a right-hand man to stephen hawking
and he said one can predict everything
about the universe from
this initial instantan the calculations
are very precise
and then we have on the other side
someone who created this inflation
and i talked about the other day
inflationary theory
that says that the universe somehow
exponentially
increased in size in the first few
microseconds
and his name is alan guth or
guth and he says the big bang theory
proposes
no answer at all to the question of what
banged
how it banged or what caused it to bang
in other words he's saying we cannot
really explain
uh you know
how the universe came into being how
matter arose from
absolutely nothing and uh so here's
uh another page and another two people
who
don't agree completely and one is
stephen hawking which died a couple
years ago in andre
lindy he's a russian who teaches at
stanford university a pretty popular guy
in in the in the world of mathematical
physics
and hockey says suggested that such a
theory might explain
no less than the initial conditions of
the universe itself
and lindy on the other hand he's got a
little
reservation he said you know it is such
an esoteric science
creation from nothing it's like a
religion
okay and so
um yeah the question is whether creation
from nothing
you know you could call it a religion
you could just say it's an irrational
explanation
ration irrational theory okay
okay and here are the models because uh
there's different models to compare
against so that you can get an idea what
these people are working on
okay and the first one and i'm gonna
talk about that a little later as well
uh in a no boundary hypothesis stephen
hawking and jim hartle
envisioned time depicted here running up
the side of a cone
emerging from space around the cone
on the other hand we have a little later
the hawking turret model
a wondrous object dubbed the p instanton
which contains a p's mass jammed into 10
to the minus 30 centimeters
sprouts into an infinite open universe
okay and then the model that these other
mathematical physicists uh support
people like lindy and so on uh a lady
known as
professor collage okay she she also
works at sanford they come up with these
models
which is the multiverse okay in the
multiverse theory our
universe may be but a tiny part of a
vast
bubble that inflated out of a
pre-existing region
similar bubbles have been forming since
time immemorial
okay so these are essentially the
competitors
in mathematical physics in physics they
have no other
ideas this is it so
if you're wondering you know how the
universe came into being if you actually
believe
that that's what happened that matter
somehow came in
from the void well these this is it
uh there's no more than these theories
out there there's modifications
to these theories there's different
branches but this is
it this is essentially it okay
and today we're going to look at how the
p instanton you know relates to this
okay here's the hawking sir turk
instantan
okay and this is also out of that
article so we're going to let them talk
it says
what emerged was a proposal dubbed the
no boundary hypothesis
it can be imagined with a little help
from a simple
geometric shape a cone imagine that the
cone represents the evolution of the
universe
time runs up the side of the cone as you
just saw a minute ago okay
while space runs around the cone okay
keep that in mind
uh time goes up on the side of the cone
and space goes around
the space is the circle so so to speak a
bunch of circles
you know going upwards okay as you go up
forward in time the width
of the cone space space right enlarges
the origin of time and space is the
point at the bottom
okay in the traditional big bang model
this
is the singularity okay so we started a
singularity
it expands and what they're saying is
that the circles
that form the cone that's space
and time really flows along the edge
of that triangle that cone okay
but in quantum physics there is no such
thing as a precise
point there is an uncertainty to it to
visualize this
imagine that the point is rounded off
okay so here we get into the hocus pocus
picture and extreme blow up of the tip
of a ballpoint
pen this is just what hardwin hawking's
paths path integral predicted
as the most likely configuration for the
universe at its birth
rather than the time dimension up the
side of the cone here it is
beginning at the discrete at a discrete
point it emerges from the space
dimension
around the cone okay what they're going
to do
is they're going to put time together
with space and say that the circles that
form
uh the cone uh that is not only space
but it's also
time okay so they're gonna have all
these rings going upwards and that's
gonna include both space and time
time is no longer along the edge of the
cone in other words okay
and just as there is no point on the
surface of a sphere
where one can say the sphere begins
there is no distinct point on the
hemispherical
rounded off bottom of the cone where
time
or space begins there simply is no
starting point
and there is no distinction between
space and time
or even past and future in essence hartl
and hawking proposed
that the universe inflated out of the
bottom of the cone
what do they mean by that they mean out
of nothing because they're saying that
you can't have a starting point on a
circle
you have space and time they're in a
circle
they're at the bottom of the cone but
the cone
is not a point it's got a rounded
point and because it's got a rounded
point and that rounded point has a
circumference or circle
or whatever and that circumference or
circle
includes both space and time neither
space and time had
an origin okay you see where they're
getting to this they're they're trying
to show that the universe did in fact
start from nothing
because time uh in space they're part of
a circle and where's the beginning and
the
ending point of a circle that's their
logic
logic i guess you can call it logic
okay okay so let's uh see what
uh what they're proposing here uh
pictorially
okay in the instant time they're saying
look we have time
as circles around the instant time okay
on the other hand you can see in
comparison to the cone time runs
up the side of the cone here it's going
around the
instant on and since it's a circle and
there's no beginning and then to a
circle
uh they're going to claim that time and
space had no beginning
just like you know there's no beginning
or end to a circle
okay that that's what they're gonna
that's their argument okay and here
uh here they more or less tell you what
it looks like says
what does this new creation model look
like they asked turk
and hawking and had imagined it using
math
well it's small and round but not
perfectly round and it has little
dimples
something like a p to reply
okay so space and time are blended
together in
in the piece such that its bottom half
is just like the rounded off tip
of the cone in the original hardell
hawking
no boundary model here again time
emerges from the geometry of space
and there is no discrete beginning to
either
okay you see what they're doing here
this is a
now by the way this is all handled
mathematically it's not like you can
imagine this in any way maybe you can
imagine that there's no beginning
and end uh on a circle
okay circular argument
yeah there's no beginning and then to a
circle there's no beginning and end
really to
any like a triangle or a square because
where do you begin at the corner well
that's arbitrary i mean you really don't
begin on any
two-dimensional figure anywhere you
don't begin
you don't have a starting point and and
same goes for three-dimensional
uh geometries take a cube take a sphere
where do you be
where's the beginning where's the end so
the question is is whether this logic
makes any sense
but this is what they're gonna talk
about this how they're gonna
they're gonna gear their math around
this notion
okay so that's that's where we're at
now theirs is not the only instant time
they had one
type of incident and here's another one
probably just as famous or probably
the one that was there before theirs
okay they they improved i guess on this
one
this was the coleman um the lucia
cosmological instanton and this
describes the creation of an open
universe
by a bubble nucleation okay they're
going to
do bubble nucleation this is a little
bit of
different concept okay that you're going
to see in a minute because i'm going to
illustrate it okay
matter in the early universe is
initially in a state
known as the false vacuum false vacuum
okay everything from mathematical
physics is false
even the vacuum okay a false vacuum is a
classically stable excited state which
is
quantum mechanically unstable
what does all that mean it means uh it's
not nothing
it's not a vacuum it's a vacuum that's
got something
in it that's what it is okay
and uh here you get a
i think i got a picture of that
there it is put it up here okay here
here's the uh famous
false vacuum of quantum okay and they
explain
this out of the wikipedia says the
energy e okay that you see down at the
bottom there uh the
y-axis i guess you could call it is
higher in the false vacuum
than that in the true vacuum of ground
or ground state
but there is a barrier preventing the
field from classically rolling down to
the true
vacuum okay therefore the transition to
the true vacuum must be stimulated by
the creation of high energy particles
or through quantum mechanical tunneling
keep that tunneling in mind we're going
to talk about that a little later but
you can see what happens uh
you get the false vacuum you can't get
to the true vacuum the only way you can
get to the true vacuum is wet tunneling
or if somehow it pushes the the um
this vacuum uh in such a way that
it overcomes that little blip that
little mountain
okay okay continuing here says in uh
quantum theory matter which is in a
false vacuum a
tunnel to its true vacuum state yeah
which is what they explain there
so you can tunnel through and
false vacuum decay proceeds via the
nucleation of bubbles
inside each bubble the matter has
tunneled and bubbly interior is an
infinite open universe in which
inflation may occur
okay inflation remember that's what uh
alan guth uh
came up with so they had to explain that
how that came about
okay so this this is essentially what
these people are saying okay
here's an illustration of this okay
here you have the false vacuum and you
have the true vacuum
as you can see on the left hand side you
have more false vacuum than true vacuum
you know all of it is false vacuum but
as time proceeded okay you have more
true vacuum or the true vacuum is
expanding
at the expense of the false vacuum and
you would think that we
arrived today where most of it is true
vacuum
but when you ask all these people they
say that the true vacuum out there is
made of particles
so i don't know what they've achieved
with this but just so that you know
there are different notions
of this instantan theory
there are different branches of it okay
and they're still developing some more
they're just brainstorming ideas and
developing them
mathematically okay so that's where
they're at today
okay um here's the punch line
from uh neil turek and hawking
and it's also from the article and that
gives you a a pretty good
idea where they stand and nothing has
changed really till today
uh of course even if turok and hawking
are onto something with their pete
instant on
it would still leave a very fundamental
question unanswered
how did the p get there yeah that's what
we all want to know
that god created turgan hawking say it's
meaningless
to ask the question ah geez just when
the question that they needed to ask
that it's meaningless it's unscientific
right
there is no outside the p no before the
p
it just is an object implied by the very
laws
of physics so they asked the next
question what created those laws how did
the laws come who
you know the laws preceded the thing
okay
who put the laws if that's gonna create
the p i said
says turok we don't know how to create
physics
from nothing 20 years later
you get the same answer we don't know
how to create anything something from
nothing and you're going to see that you
know people like
larry uh what's his name um
lawrence krauss larry cross he'll say
the universe from nothing and how can
that possibly how can you imagine a
universe from nothing
if you cannot uh justify or explain the
mechanism
you know please illustrate it and of
course they can't do that it's just blah
blah blah just a lot of wording
and they say here's the equation and
that's it that's all they have
and when you press them even further
they say well we don't know how to
create something from nothing
you know in the end they all give you
the same answer so
i don't know what all these people do
for a living all they do is just
come up with nonsense they make
startling statements and people say oh
the
physicist the scientist he said this and
he's got to know because he knows all
this math and nobody knows so if he says
that
the universe came from nothing he must
be so
and and obviously uh you know a lot of
people like uh christians
religious people they like that to some
degree they just say well they just
don't want to say that god did it but
we know you know we know god was there
and he created the first
uh particle or whatever okay so here we
have
the two areas you know so-called
mathematical physics supposedly science
that stands against religion
and they have the same religion they
both believe that the universe came from
nothing that there was an
origin to the universe in one case you
have god and the other one you know and
you have this
instant on when you ask them what is the
incident how did that came into being
well they say it's an unreasonable
question that you're asking
love it you know just the question i
needed answered and they don't answer i
thought that's what the
the dissertation was going to be about
right
where did all this nonsense come from
how did we end up
like this well it all starts with mr
newton
okay uh one way of looking at it okay
here we have newton he came up with
his little equation force equals mass
times acceleration
his so-called second law okay of motion
okay you push the ball and moves out
okay so we have mass and we have
acceleration
straight forward okay what happened next
or
i guess in the chronology i'm missing a
lot of intermediate steps okay i'm just
gonna go
whiz through it real quick we have mr
lagrange
okay and he said uh well i can do newton
too
but i i'm gonna do it differently i'm
gonna have this t
minus v and you say what the hell's t
minus v well you have the potential
energy
minus the kinetic energy
and he was able to explain that to some
to a great extent
in order to not explain but describe
that you know like in a case of a
pendulum if you if the pendulum goes up
at some point it stops so you have no
kinetic energy it's almost
all potential energy which
you know starts declining as you go in
the opposite direction
okay but he was able to explain a lot of
things using this
this viva which was really the kinetic
energy
so instead of talking in terms of mass
and acceleration they started talking in
terms of
energy and time so that kind of change
that new mathematics was developed
okay and then we could explain the same
things in terms of
describe the same things in terms of
energy and time okay
so that's 18th century this is when this
started
moving along okay
uh what happened next well here we have
uh something was happening really
in parallel to all this and it's
important to understand this to see how
we got to the instant time
uh first we have here on of uh
alexandria
and uh i put alexander's alexandria
okay and uh he came up with the shortest
distance for for example
light or the the separation between two
points
the what unites them is a straight line
and that's the shortest distance
fermat comes a few centuries later he
says oh how about the shortest time
you know and again he applied that to
light he says
light up travels in the shortest time
possible
in other words his travels straight okay
uh euler uh swiss guy
uh mathematician he uh took some of
these ideas
and he figured out that if you take the
derivatives
at um maximum and minimum points
along a curve uh they are
zero and why again because a derivative
is a change
in um in the rate of
the it's the rate of change of motion
okay and
there is no rate of change of motion
when you reach a zenith
like when you throw a ball up at some
point it's got to come down okay
and when it goes up and it stops well at
that point the
rate of change is zero okay so
healer came up with that and then we
have this fellow william hamilton
uh you probably heard of the hamiltonian
just like you heard
of the lagrangian and this is what these
guys refer to
and uh what hamilton came up with which
really is breathtaking
is stationary action
stationary action what does that mean it
means that
you move while standing still there is
motion
but there's only location or position
it's static and dynamic and condensing
room to one
and so you say you know how to come up
with that well you see the red path
there
what they do is they say this path has
stationary
action because mathematically you take
its derivative and it's zero
okay that's essentially what
these people are saying and what
uh you know you wonder about people like
um
heisenberg werner heisenberg he came up
with the uncertainty
principle it says that the more you know
about um
what is it more you know about position
the less you know about momentum or vice
versa the more you know about momentum
the less you know about position
uh again that's along the same line of
reasoning
what they're saying is that they don't
understand the difference between
standing still and moving
because you know when the ball stands
still doesn't move
and yeah the more you know about
standing still the less you know about
moving and the more you know about
moving the less you know about standing
still
and heisenberg got a noble for proving
that mathematically
and it comes from these notions that
these mathematicians invented
and they have little to do with physics
they have all to do with mathematics
so what happens next well um
a lot of the uh mathematical physicists
physicists with quotations that came
after started playing around with these
notions one of them was paul dirac
in the 1930s he toyed around with this
but i'm going to skip over him a little
bit go to
a person who really developed some of
this to a greater extent which was
richard feynman
and it turns out that feynman you know
he was kind of like a young guy but he
was working
at uh alamos uh
with a bomb and in 1948 they had a
little
powwow uh pocono pennsylvania all the
conference uh all these uh
people who worked on the bomb came over
a lot of them
that worked on the bottom came over and
they talked about so-called physics
mathematical physics
okay especially about qed
quantum electrodynamics and among the
people who came not someone who worked
on the bomb but niels bohr
came um paul durakian
the guy who organized it was uh robert
oppenheimer who
who was the guy who was in charge the
manager the director of
the bomb project okay so all these
people got together in pennsylvania
there and they had a little pow wow and
uh
among the people who gave a dissertation
was feinman
and in the audience again we had niels
bohr
and oppenheimer and durack and
whitner eugene wigner for those of you
who know him
you know they had all these old timers
and they were listening to this
new generation of quantum mechanics
they didn't like it one bit in fact we
have uh
what's his name um jim uh alkali
and this comes from his mouth okay he's
got i'm just gonna repeat what he said
okay and uh he says the following
uh where is he
i can get it up here here it is uh this
is what uh jamal khalili says he says uh
because he dared to visualize what was
going on
instead of using arcane complicated
mathematics
feynman was describing what all his
virtual particles were up to using his
simple pictures
the so-called you know finding diagrams
okay
there was an uproar niels bohr the
father of quantum mechanics
left from his chair in disgust he hated
finding
finance diagrams because they were
completely against everything he devoted
his whole life to
you see he believed that atomic
particles could not be visualized
under any circumstances feynman defended
his new theory
tried to explain that the diagrams were
simply a tool to help visualize his new
equations
but the rest of the scientists including
paul dirac wouldn't hear of it
they called him an idiot who understood
nothing about quantum mechanics okay
and uh it's important to know that
uh you know
good old born iraq and oppenheimer all
the rest they didn't realize but there
was a revolution
underway and one of those people was
uh finally with schwinger
uh tono maga some of these people later
on were going to win
nobel prizes after the old guard was
gone because what happened
in the 50s and 60s and really it starts
taking off in the 70s
is that quantum change altogether
completely and nobody noticed
uh you know people like niels bohr and
werner heisenberg these people were
particle people they believed in
discrete particles they explained
everything or described everything with
discrete particles
mathematically it was pinpoint particle
that's what they were thinking of
the electron was a little particle the
photon was a little particle
and it was people like einstein and
schrodinger and
de broglie these were the people who
were thinking
in terms of waves and elongated things
well now you've got the new generation
of mechanics
people like feynman they come in and
they said look
you know they're bringing back the
notion of continuity
you know here you have constant
interactions and
interaction leads to more interaction
into more interaction and more
interactions
so a photon breaks up according to paul
direct
into you know an electron and a positron
and they blend together and they form a
photon again or release a photon so they
have this continuity
and what they did you know since they
couldn't explain action at a distance
what they started
doing more and more were waves
and fields what you have is the
uh arising the birth
of quantum field theory so no longer
were they talking about little discrete
particles pinpoint particles that you
could say okay this one's over here that
one's over there and
they didn't even know where they were
they just had this probability
um uh
volume okay a volume of probability
and that's where you could find the
particle somewhere in there and there
was a greater possible
probability of finding it here than it
was over there that sort of thing
but these guys come up and they said no
you're talking about a field
and the particle is really vibration of
a field
localized vibrational field but the
field extends
all the way to the edge of space-time so
they were introducing a new concept here
they were introducing
an uh elongated entity
from a mathematical point of view they
were going to talk about fields and of
course every now and then they put in
the wave
okay so this is the this was a
revolution
on in in the uh making and of course uh
what is it uh board died in what 1962
65 they give a nobel prize to people
like schwinger and uh
fighting okay because the new generation
had now taken over
there was a revolution okay so uh
we have this little revolution what was
this revolution about well feynman
is gonna invent something called the
path integral okay
and again he's going to borrow these
ideas from
his predecessors the mathematicians of
the 16th 17th 18th century and 19th
century you know these people came up
with these notions of what
of stationary action and he kind of
liked that he said stationary action
it sounds like you can explain a lot
with that because you don't have to
include
motion in there and you treat two points
the beginning and the end point as
simultaneous
that's more or less what these people
are going to do from a conceptual
point of view okay so invents this path
integral
you say what's all that about well uh
you have this
particle and moves from a to b very
simple straight forward right
he's got a space-time diagram okay and
particle moves from a to b
but according to quantum mechanics the
particle can go through
any path
and it's even worse it does
go through all possible imaginable
paths paths it um
it does in fact go through all these
paths according to quantum mechanics
it takes all these routes to get from a
to b a quantum particle
okay so it's not only it's not only that
it can
it does and so
you say well hold it something seems to
be wrong with that i mean you're saying
look you have all these curves obviously
the one that goes in a straight line
gets there faster than the guy going
around
for example take the photon travels at
300 000 kilometers per second
so if if what was it here on
says straight line uh the other guy said
at least fairmont says
least time great we've got it and so
uh you say well uh you know that's the
least time that's
that's how the photon would go
so what is this nonsense about the
photon going all around the universe
just to get the b obviously it would
take
more time and then there was the issue
of
what is all this for what do we need
this for
and see you need you need this let me
tell you why because
quantum you can talk magic you can say
anything you want
but then when you come to the real world
you know the what is known as the
classical world the
macro world or our macro world the world
of
anything above atom now you have to
interface
your quantum world with this world
because there is
an interaction light does interact with
atoms
and so you can say anything you want
about light in the quantum world
just invent anything it comes out of
your mind that's fine no problem
but now you have to relate it to the
real world because we do receive
light and we have to explain the
interaction between light from the
quantum world
with atoms many of the real world
so there is an interface so you have to
kind of explain that and justify that
you know from the quantum point of view
okay how did this particle from
from here go from a to b b being
you know the atom where it hit or or
struck or whatever or was absorbed
you got to explain that you got to
justify that in some kind of way
and these people don't do it physically
they do it mathematically okay so so
this is what they had to explain
or these were some of the
characteristics that they were
addressing
okay some particularities of um
of of this path integral why it was
necessary in a
and other little quirks that we need to
iron out and so here's the problem we
have to expre
approximate quantum the classical
mechanics to explain actual visible
measurable interactions okay so this was
a little bit of
a problem for the people who were doing
quantum they had to relate it somehow
to the real world in which we live the
macro world
uh you got to keep in mind quantum
mechanics is primarily a probabilistic
theory okay it's a probability thing
okay they work primarily out of
probabilities because again it's a
mathematical theory
uh which is not a theory it's really a
description the theory is what's
irrational
all wide-ranging ridiculous itineraries
happen
but have little probability of
influencing the outcome only the
sensible
with quotations sensible paths are
are included okay so what they do all
these other
ones that go throughout the universe
they're not sensible even though they
happen
they're not sensible and the the
probability the likelihood of them
influencing the outcome is minimal or
negligible or
inexistent you could say so what they do
is they get rid of these they say well
we don't care about that one it's not
that
they're saying it doesn't happen they
say it does happen but we don't pay
attention
to it because you know it's it it
doesn't
really affect the outcome that's their
that's their argument for that
most itineraries cancel out anyways you
know
for example you can have destructive
interference one itinerary goes one way
the other one goes the other way or
they're
or they're in parallel but they're
offset
you know so they have what they call
destructive interference and so they
don't affect the outcome
either and then to be consistent with
special relativity
every photon carries its own clock and
measures its own proper time so you say
hold it
uh one of those kurticus went through
the entire universe yeah don't worry
about it because see
uh that's according to your eyes
according to the
photon it's carrying its own clog and it
measures its own proper time
so this is another answer they give you
then the other thing you have to keep in
mind is that
time under this uh mathematical
scheme is imaginary okay
i call it irrational they call it
imaginary why imaginary because it's got
square root of minus one
there's no such monster so anytime you
see the
square root of minus one that's replaced
by the tiny letter i
and that means imaginary and what they
do they do a little
mathematical footwork there called a
transformation
and they morph this 3d plus one time
again uh imaginary time world
into a 4d uh scenario platform
okay so there's a lot of fudging around
from a mathematical point of view to get
this
done but they love it because primarily
because
of that stationary action thing
that hamilton came out with and that's
why they always talk
they talk about the hamiltonian
and you say what the hell was that oh
man that's over my head no it just means
that
stationary motion that's what it means
okay it means that when the ball moves
it doesn't stand still when it stands
still it doesn't move they don't know
the difference between motion
and location in other words that's
that's the problem and again it's
because they never defined any of these
terms
all they do is mathematics equations and
then they invent all these concepts to
try to get their equation through
and this is what they work on that's
what you're paying your tax dollars for
to all these institutions that work on
these things
okay let's find out how this works
here's a visual representation i try to
do
for those so that you can visualize what
they're trying to do
let's assume you have a ball a bunch of
balls okay
and you're throwing them against the
wall think of them as photons
okay in discrete particles okay so here
you have
a whole bunch of particles and they're
hearing some kind of barrier
okay if you say i understand that and
they hit a barrier fine
no problem uh what what should you
expect from a photon well you should
expect
a uh reflection you know they the
photons hit the barrier and they
reflect it turns out that when they do
this with some
quantum particles it could be an
electron it could be photons whatever
they realize that some of the particles
go past the barrier
okay and you say hold it uh how did it
go through the barrier it's a particle
how did it pass the barrier it's a
physical barrier and the particle goes
right through
and so they have to explain this
phenomena or what they think is
happening there
and for this they needed this uh
stationary action
notion because they have to explain how
this particle ends up on the other side
and for this it's very handy to have all
these derivatives first
and also to have elongated entities such
as waves
and fields because a field is not a
localized entity it's an extended
entity so that's when you know quantum
field
theory kind of takes off because they
say hey we like this because
now if we're going to explain something
like tunneling which is what this is
called
we can use some of these notions we can
use this notion where the
particle appears on the other side
instantaneously first
and second we can explain uh
with the field why it's an extended
entity rather than
a localized particle okay so this is
what they're gonna do they're gonna
replace this notion of quantum with the
field notion
or the wave you could even say the wave
notion okay
okay so now what they can do with this
is say well you know what
we do is we're just going to replace all
this with waves
okay and so we have the wave coming in
and some wave goes through the barrier
okay
so now that we're talking about waves
well yeah now you're talking about
spirits okay
you can do anything with spirits and so
you can claim that yeah
uh well first of all here you have um
that the only
condition here is that they realize that
the wave loses its amplitude
okay so when it goes to the other side
the wave loses its amplitude
but what they can claim now is that yeah
you have particles coming in
and what you have on the other side is
waves and when the wave
when you measure the wave it collapses
to a particle
okay so uh that's that's quantum in a
nutshell
you know as soon as you take a
measurement the the field the wave
whatever
condenses and uh collapses
into a particle and now you can take a
measurement or
it's simultaneous when you take the
measurement it
suddenly you know from every part of the
universe it condenses
into this little tiny speck and that's
what you
measure and when you take the uh
it's like you know mother nature father
universe god the devil whoever is
watching you and
saying oh he's going to take a
measurement yeah yeah i'm going to take
a measurement as soon as you touch the
thing they go hocus pocus and the
whole thing you know draws together and
condenses into a point
you say hey it's a point every time i
measure it's a point as soon as you take
the measurement away whatever you're
measuring
it goes back to being a wave a field an
extended
entity and yeah with this obviously you
can get around a lot
a lot of questions because uh anyone who
asks you you just give them that answer
and the
person said well i still don't
understand well you got to take math
you got to go through all the pain i
went through in order to understand this
all this nonsense okay that's the way it
works
okay so let's continue here
when all is said and done what is all
this instant on about well
it's uh what is the definition what what
is an instant on how does it
fall in with all this well an instantane
is a classical
solution to an equation of motion with
finite nonzero action
a solution to the imaginary time another
the first one was i think from the
wikipedia the second one is from
cambridge
site physics site a solution to the
imaginary time
non-linear field equation of yang mills
field theory
carries information about quantum tunnel
so what is it it's a solution to an
equation that's what an instantane
is so what was this nonsense that turk
was saying that it looks like a p
we got a little problem here because
here these people are saying it's a
solution which is a
concept they're saying it's a solution
to an equation
to a problem or whatever okay and this
guy says yeah it looks like a pig with
little dimples and
it's got a big nose and looks like santa
claus i guess
i don't know why did they draw it
if they're talking about a solution to
an equation to to a problem
what does that have to do with physics
with with an
object that we're staring at over there
well
they had to do this because they have to
explain why
time and space did not have an origin
from a pictorial point of view and they
say well imagine it is a circle
and so it's got no beginning and end and
so there that's how we do it
mathematically and when we extrapolate
our
mathematics to the visual world this is
what we come up with some kind of p
that has space and time wound around it
with no beginning or end to space or
time
and so this is how they end up saying to
you that
space and time came out of nowhere
because they didn't need a nowhere
because
it's like they were there all the time
the circle was always over there
and you can't imagine where time and
space
uh start on a circle
that's the reasoning that's how these
people look at this
okay okay here's the
cambridge these are the followers of uh
stephen hawking this is what they put in
their site okay
and uh this is essentially their summary
of this cosmological instant on
this is what is today okay so this is
actual okay this is what they're working
on this is what they spend their time on
calculating and doing equations on this
nonsense okay
during inflation quantum mechanical
vacuum fluctuations
are amplified okay and due to the
accelerating expansion of the universe
they are stretched to macroscopic
length scales in other words they have
to explain how the instanton has
something to do with
the beginning of the universe okay so
that's
where they're putting it in there and
again you got to keep this notion
of uh uh you know static
motion static dynamics i guess you could
call it
stationary action whatever that means to
you uncertainty principle when it moves
it doesn't stand still
or maybe it does both who knows okay
and it says
later on when the universe has cooled
they seed the growth so you have these
vacuum fluctuations they're going to
seed the growth they're going to
pump the energy of the universe so it
starts getting
bigger of large-scale structures example
you know galaxies
like those we see today and here's the
proof the evidence
one sees the imprint of these primordial
fluctuations
as small temperature perturbations
in the cosmic small microwave background
radiation
the cmb so that's the proof they say
look when you see these vibrations ah
that's the vacuum fluctuations from the
uh instant ton that started our universe
okay that's the origin of space and time
from where matter eventually arose right
we saw that the other day
since different types of instantons
predict slightly different fluctuation
spectra
the temperature perturbations in the
cosmic microwave background radiation
will depend on the
instantan from which the universe was
created how do you like that as a story
for a bedtime story for babies okay
yeah some of these people really have
some
fancy notions well all i can do is give
you my summary
okay so here's uh bill gates summary on
the so-called instanton that gave the
the god particle that gave origin to the
universe okay this is what i think of it
okay
uh pseudo particle called instanton
because it's a pseudo quasi
particle because they're all crazy
the quasis the quasis and the pseudos
okay called instantan from
instant that's where it comes from okay
because it happens in an instant there's
essentially you know what is it um
stationary action
okay is a solution to an equation that's
what it is
that's what they all that's what they
all do that's what they're all trying to
figure out
they're trying to look for an equation
that will give them uh
you know the essentially the unification
of all forces
all four forces so far they have
supposedly
uh the electro weak now they're trying
to incorporate
uh you know first the gravity the gluon
and
the strong force and then the uh the
graviton the gravitational force
it was invented to account for action at
a distance phenomena
that quantum mechanics will never be
able to explain with discrete particles
the instantan solution okay that's a
solution only
is a stand-in for what stationary action
that's what it is that's why it's
instant they're saying there's motion
there's action there's whatever but it's
instant it's in a single frame of the
universal from
movie the instant on in effect treats
start
and end points are simultaneous that's
what essentially what they do
but they do it through a mathematical
trick where they say we're going to take
the derivative
of this uh length
we're going to treat it as as almost a
straight line or the average of that
straight line we're going to take the
derivative and the derivative of zero so
we have no motion we have no
uh change in the rate
okay so that's the notion
in general terms the incident comes in
handy
in to explain action at a distance
phenomena such as tunneling
and what how the universe came into
being instantaneously
without a cause and what's my corollary
the instantan
gives job security to a generation of
mathematicians that have nothing
else to work on that's what you're
paying for
that's what your tax dollars are going
into
okay so that's the end of the
instant done for today
okay folks let's look at some of the
questions and comments people made
let's go with the first one here
okay fellow says uh related to i guess
last week
beyond human visualization or
imagination
there is no reality this is conclusion
of what you talk
or i guess he's affirming that and
no no you got it wrong okay and this
is again people have it all wrong why
because they introduced an observer
so he's saying uh what you're saying is
what you visualize what you imagine
no no that's not that's not reality
okay so let's clarify that very clearly
okay
let's make it obvious so here it is
here's my answer to that
okay oh come on
reality has nothing to do with what
human
uh you know observers visualization
imagination
observation tangibility perception
feeling consciousness verification
experimentation proving sensations etc
what we do in science we define the word
reality to begin with so we know what
we're talking about
what is reality it's a synonym of exist
actual reel etc
what is it an object plus location what
is it
uh what i synthesize as
um what is it um
i forgot the term now essentially you
know you need an object and it has to
have location
physical presence that's what i was
thinking of okay physical presence
so uh no reality is not what you
perceive
or imagine in reality you have to define
the term
and i define it you need an object and
that object has to have location
then you have reality okay that you can
say that object is real
or that object exists so it's not what
you visualize
i can visualize god that doesn't make
him exist i can visualize or imagine a
chair
that chair doesn't exist a square
doesn't exist okay and i can imagine a
square
also but that square doesn't exist
neither the one
that i wrote on paper what exists are
the
is the ink and the paper but not the
square the square
is an object an object because it has
shape that's the only condition for for
the word object it has to have
shape that's it uh does the shape
does that square exist no squares don't
exist they have no location so you won't
find one out there in space okay so
don't look for it
okay square is that which has shape
and therefore it's an object period
that's the definition of
object it applies to any object it's the
only
um property attribute that all
objects in the universe it's it's the
universal property of all objects
shape not all objects can be touched
not all objects can be seen not all
objects exist
and uh the only property again
is uh shape okay so that's it
anyone who doesn't like that you don't
have to agree with me
the only way you can overcome that is
come into the ring with your own
definition
you have to have a definition for object
otherwise you can't talk about object
and
we shouldn't even listen to you right
because if you don't have a definition
for the word
object which is absolutely necessary in
physics because
physics cannot be done with without
objects
physics is the science that deals with
objects
okay you wouldn't have anything to study
or
analyze or whatever there were no
objects so you need to define the word
object for the purposes of physics
so before you can attack my definition
you have to put your
definition it's just that simple if you
don't have a definition you can't even
talk you got to shut your mouth
and listen only when you have a
definition that applies to all
objects that you can use consistently
scientifically
in physics then can you you know bring
it in here
okay so that's where it starts okay
another issue
again more or less related to what i
talked about the other day
okay and the fellow says uh god as
master designer and creator is not a
belief
faith or religion it's a logical
conclusion
everything beyond that is a theory
opinion
[Laughter]
oh man so many errors in just one
just a couple sentences okay let's find
out if we can find out all the years
in here okay yeah obviously a person
has serious problems right okay so let's
find out
here it is if god is designer and or
creator then god is an object
by definition what is an object that
which has shape
god is not a concept under that if he's
master designer creator
why because a concept is a word that
embodies two
objects that's a short version okay so
god is an object and there you see god
creating the universe he's the designer
he's the creator
you can see something there for god
right there is a shape
so if god has shape god is an object
you're treating god as an
object no matter what and again if you
don't like the definition of object you
have only one recourse and that
is to define the word object come into
the ring defend your definition with
sword and shield okay and god is not a
logical conclusion it's known as an
assumption
you make an assumption say let us assume
god
is that fellow that's down there with a
magic wand
okay so you're saying that you're
imagining that god
is an object okay a thing and in this
case because he's got
shape okay so that's the first condition
and then if you want to say that god
exists all you have to say is he has
location we will assume that god has
location
what do we mean by that means that you
can establish a distance
between your your chest and god's chest
or between your eye and god's eye
there's distance between the two of you
and god has location with respect to the
other matter in the universe
that's what we mean by god exists god
has to have
location if he wants to exist okay so
it's not enough for god to be an
object god must in addition okay
have location and then a theory is not
an opinion like this vowel says
that is a theory opinion no opinion is
religion
theory is an explanation okay so no
theory is not an opinion
a religion is opinion okay so
let's make sure we we separate those
okay let me get back in here
and next issue next question next
comment fellow says
survey says you can simply google
physics definitions because i i asked
them to go
and look for definitions a scientific
definition
of the word object uh i think concept
exists
okay so you have to go out there and
look for a definition a scientific one
from a scientific dictionary because he
says there's scientific
dictionaries out there and he says they
don't agree with me yeah i don't care if
they agree with me or not that's
irrelevant
uh we want to make sure that they make
sense and that they can defend their
definitions
and if someone vouches for those
definitions it's he who has to go into
the ring and
and defend those definitions for the
dictionary okay
and if he doesn't know enough he's got
to do his research and find out how he's
going to defend that definition
he can't just transcribe a definition
from the dictionary and says
oh this is the one i'm going to use now
if it's an irrational definition you
don't want to use it for sure
not in science at least and he says an
object has to be three-dimensional
there are objects that again we don't
know until he's gonna define
the word object we don't know what he
means by that you know why he
comes up with his criterion that an
object has to be three-dimensional
this is arbitrary and it's got to be
founded on a definition of the word
object and again since he didn't put a
definition
a scientific definition we don't know
what what he means by the word object
therefore it's very arbitrary and
opinionated
to just say it's got to be
three-dimensional and
again three dimension is the notion of
ordinary speech not a scientific
definition okay so keep those in mind a
rock is an object that doesn't
experience existing
hopefully uh you didn't need to say that
i'm sure a lot of people
i mean i don't know your asylum if they
if the rocks have
experienced anything okay a circle
square triangle
are not objects or concept we call them
geometry okay whatever
whatever objects whatever you mean by
object you have to tell us what an
object is before you make that statement
okay until you can tell us what an
object is scientifically and defend that
definition
you got nothing shadow is a
two-dimensional geometry
casted uh from an interference of light
by an object yeah
what i said is uh shadow means
blocked light and there is no physical
stand-alone object called blocked light
aside from the fact that a shadow has no
starting point i mean if you're going to
talk about shape
shape is all around okay that's shape
and
no shadow has shape all around okay what
shadows have
they have you know they start at at the
feet of
whoever's getting the shadow and even if
you take a like i showed the other day
even if you take a light and pointed in
the middle of space at
uh i don't know a
planet and somehow you project that onto
a screen
okay that shadow comes all the way to
the planet
so it starts at the planet it's not that
it's just standalone out there
that shadow is blocked light and black
light goes all the way from the object
that's blocking light all the way to the
shadow
so again it's not an independent thing
and second it doesn't have shape
because shape extends all the way to the
object
okay so it's a three-dimensional shape
you could say but even that is not a
shape because it's not standalone
okay shape shape means you got something
there and
and you can see it you know
independently and you can't do that with
the shadow shadow goes all the way to
your feet
prove that to yourself go out into the
sun one day and you'll find out that the
shadow that the the feet of your shadow
go all the way to your feet
and extends all the way to your body
there is no such thing and in that case
the
the light that's being blocked is uh you
know uh
uh in in a uh slanted in a
some degrees because it goes from your
head downwards so all that
all that space between you and your
shadow your two-dimensional shadow there
you know
all that three-dimensional volume that's
that whole thing is the shadow
it's called the penumbra or the umbra
depending on
which portion you're talking about okay
so uh here's the answer
formal answer to this gentleman
and here it is okay all the things none
of these are definitions
these are examples without any
foundation or
unscientific opinions that's all he's
got there when googling definition of
object for physics we find the following
we find a wikipedia you can do this on
your own you don't have to take my word
for it just google
definition of object or definition of
object for science or for physics or for
whatever
and you'll find this same thing i found
and now find
wikipedia an object is an identifiable
collection of matter
which is the definition this fellow used
the other day again he took it from the
wikipedia because there is no scientific
definition of the word object
then uh another one you'll find is uh
one in hub pages uh guy says what is an
object
for physics and he's got the same
definition that i have
and there you find the link so you can
look it up
and that'd be nice if this fellow would
put links instead of just uh
giving examples and just giving his
opinion i mean
if if he's got a scientific definition
from a scientific dictionary
all he's got to do is put the link and
we'll we'll check it out
okay so if he can't put a link he
doesn't have a scientific definition
from a scientific dictionary okay
and then the last one there object
anything that has no internal structure
that's what bozeman
science came uh up with on youtube and
there's the link you can look it up
so again um he says the only object that
exists essentially or that
is an object is an electron
again no internal structure what is
structure
is a synonym of object
and what is anything which is the word
he used also synonym of object
in other words this fellow who runs his
bozeman
site he has no clue whatsoever okay he
doesn't know what an object is for the
purposes of physics because he would not
be able to defend that definition
he just said it okay and so yeah there
is no scientific definition of the word
object
and the only way you're going to show it
one one of two ways either put a link
so that we can check it out objectively
and say
see what that definition says and see if
that definition
can be defended because you got to
defend the definition it's not just
saying well this is what
i found in a dictionary what's that
that's nothing
you got to defend it otherwise it's
worthless you know endeavor
and then the other one is uh you know
write your definition
whatever definition you think it is and
again be able to defend
and so far this fellow has not come
through he he has not been able to do
that
okay here's another common question
issue fellow says
rational science is also i think it's
the same guy rational science is also
based from belief
believing science doesn't include
observation
experimentation geometry mathematics
well for this again you have to define
what we mean by science okay that's all
you got to do
once you define the word science we know
what we're talking about okay here it is
we have a definition and you don't have
to agree with it again all you have to
do is challenge it and the way you
challenge it is
producing a better mousetrap and the way
you do that is saying look i've got a
better definition than you do okay
defend it
okay here it is okay here's our
definition of science okay
rational explanations that's it that's
the definition of science
okay and it's divided into branches
philosophy and
uh physics one deals with objects causes
and mechanisms the other one primarily
with reasons and purpose
okay behavior we're trying to explain
behavior
okay and here's a final point on that
one
just a kind of like a summary okay
and so you have science rational
explanations divided into those two
uh regions okay now religion is just
opinions and beliefs
that's what it is okay if you have just
an opinion
of belief you have a religion and we all
have a religion by the way we all have
beliefs we all have opinions
we just have to distinguish religion
from science
okay and now in science we do not use
the senses because the senses
makes it subjective so we do not do
experiments
why because rational because science is
rational explanations
we don't care how many experiments you
did and it doesn't matter if you did
because it doesn't mean you understood
what you did
so who cares if you did 100 times an
experiment 100 times
if you cannot explain what you did what
are you going to do just describe the
experiment say
well i dropped the pen 100 times and it
always fell to the floor
oh great i mean you know so is the
experiment
part of science no the part of science
the the juice
is the explanation if you can explain
why the cause
the mechanism of why the pen fell to the
floor then
then you have uh science otherwise all
you have is an
experiment with ignorance okay
we don't have truth fact or knowledge
proof we don't present evidence because
we're not trying to convince anyone i
mean you can produ
introduce evidence but that's part of
religion okay that's that's
that's that attacks belief opinion
uh we have no use for consciousness
sensations perception again we don't use
the senses because
the only sense we use is common sense
the least common of all senses
okay and then you have irrational
explanation there are those all on the
right you have
specifically ones that i want to mention
is theism
atheism and agnosticism all those three
are irrational theories
because they rely on belief on on
religion on what's in the center there
and the same for mathematical physics
whether you do
general relativity quantum mechanics or
string theory all you have is
an irrational explanation for how this
universe works
okay and irrationals distinguish from
supernatural
in that supernatural you can imagine the
objects you can imagine god you can
imagine an angel
you can imagine the devil okay what you
cannot imagine is the mechanism
in the case of uh mathematical physics
and
atheism all these we have something
different we we cannot imagine the
objects
okay that's the problem they don't have
objects what they have is concept
they're moving concepts around they move
energy
and they move uh fields
and they move waves and vortices and
ether and all these other plasma all
these other concepts
they say i'm moving plasma now you can't
move plasma because plasma
is already in motion you can't move
what's already in motion okay
so yeah they're moving they're moving
concept especially dynamic concepts
around they don't even realize that so
they talk about
ether plasma they talk about
energy and feels as if they were
physical objects
and they don't realize that these are
all mathematical
concepts with that i'm going to see you
on sunday